I suffer from tension? 75% of adults were stressed at levels ranging from
Moderate to high last month, there must be some solution.
So what are the best scientific methods to deal with stress and anxiety?
How can you really relax and calm your mind and body? They say laughter is the best medicine, and it shows us
It is also a medicine for stress, because when we laugh the amount of oxygen increases and stimulates [release] endorphins.
Studies have shown that even just waiting to watch a funny movie can increase the levels of endorphins beta to
27% and lead to low levels of stress hormone in the bloodstream.
After watching a funny movie, the stress hormone (cromogranin A) decreased in participants in their saliva.
And as long as you are in the cinema why not kiss with someone? It reduces cortisol and increases
Oxytocin from the pituitary gland in the brain which creates feelings of attachment, bonding,
Satisfaction and security, participants in the study who accepted their partners regularly within six weeks had lower cholesterol levels
Of course some frankincense may help your breath
However, a Japanese study also found that those who chew frankincense twice a day for two weeks
They felt more comfortable. While other participants chewed frankincense while carrying out a stressful task
They also showed lower levels of cortisol in saliva than those who did not chew frankincense.
Not because of the components of frankincense,
But it is simply a munching action known as kneading.
This recurrent movement is directly related to increased brain activity of the brain and relaxation.
The time spent in nature or even a simple plant nursery can also lower stress levels.
In 1982 the Japanese government began a forced fishing campaign or "Shinrin Yoku"
Which aims to raise awareness of the benefits of spending time in the forest for this purpose. Once a short visit to the forest
Cortisol levels, heart rate and blood pressure showed a decrease.
Even hospital patients who have a window overlooking nature tend to be better at tolerating the pain
Their recovery rates are faster compared to those who have encountered only a blank wall.
Talking about the leaves of nature, although the sense of relaxation of tea may be just an illusion,
But looking to perform rituals associated with feelings of relaxation may be a self-fulfilling prophecy.
In other words, if you are mentally preparing to relax with your favorite sedative tea
Or relax with scented oils, our brain starts to slow down and we feel better.
The amygdala in the brain is responsible for managing the emotion
It is directly related to our olfactory system.
The inhalation of a candle that brings back a childhood memory as a memory of an apple pie may well help to relive those moments, creating a better mood.
Music can have the same effect. Cut 60 to 80 beats per minute
Without words have led to stress reduction even in patients who have undergone various types of surgeries.
If you can get a pet or be next to it, do not hesitate. Having a dog is associated with low anxiety,
12% versus 21% for those without a dog.
Dog breeders have shown low levels of cortisol
And an increase in oxytocin levels.
Finally, some people relax and concentrate using the "fidget"
That's why we made her own video.
Game Gen by people, is it effective or not?
Learn more about this video by clicking on the screen or using the link in the description and signing up for more weekly science videos.
Translation: team translate autrjim @